ALEKSEY: So we're back here at
Devoxx, and I'm here with Sam
Dutton to talk about
disruptive media.
That's what your--
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, absolutely.
ALEKSEY: --session was called.
So you're working on standards,
and you believe
standards can actually
help to create
stimulate content creation.
And by content creation, we mean
maybe are you an artist,
and we can bring to the
web something that
was not there today.
So tell me what--
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, sure.
We're really looking forward
to seeing what
people make of WebRTC.
I mean, at this point, it's been
kind of in the hands of
people who do telephony and
videoconferencing and so on.
But I think what's really
exciting is what web
developers are going to make,
because they're going do a
whole stack of creative
stuff with that now.
It's fantastic.
ALEKSEY: So WebRTC is just one
of the technologies, and we'll
talk about that.
Is that part of a bigger
picture, or is that the one
and only thing you need?
SAM DUTTON: So WebRTC has
several components.
So you need some way to get
streaming media to work with
WebRTC, so that has the
Media Stream API.
People have done some stuff
already, some great demos,
using getUserMedia with that.
And then the kind of meat of
the project is this thing
called RTC PeerConnection, which
is the bit that deals
with streaming data between
the two peers.
ALEKSEY: And peers
are browsers.
There's no--
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
and a peer is
ALEKSEY: --separation
involved in there.
SAM DUTTON: No, that's right.
So just to kind of rewind a bit,
what we've had with the
internet is that with the web,
we've had this kind of--
I don't know--
kickstarting of the
information age.
We've had this ability to kind
of share information, to
create stuff and distribute it,
and then to discover stuff
and to actually consume content
and services and
media and so on.
Now, that's great, but there's
been this kind of missing
piece, which is the business of
kind of person to person,
like person-to-person
communication.
This is kind of one of the last
really major challenges
for the web.
And this is what we need with
real-time communication.
And that's what WebRTC
is bringing to us.
ALEKSEY: And this is what
used to cost a lot and
systems can do that.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, yeah.
ALEKSEY: We technically
can do that today.
SAM DUTTON: Absolutely.
Yeah, sure.
ALEKSEY: But the web can make
that accessible to--
take it to the next level.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, yeah.
So what we've had in the past
is kind of corporate closed
systems that have--
some have worked better than
others, but they've always
been expensive to implement and
difficult to integrate.
And of course, there's never
been a way to directly
integrate stuff with
your web apps.
What we have now is the use of
plug-ins like Flash, which
work well in many ways, but are
problematic and that are
essentially closed
and are separate.
And also thinking about
security, they're not part of
the sandbox browser
environment.
So WebRTC has also been built
with security in mind using
secure protocols, and because
it's within the browser,
continually updated,
sandboxed.
It's inherently more secure.
ALEKSEY: So what do you send?
What kind of data
can you share?
I mean, developers care
about that, obviously.
SAM DUTTON: It's exciting to
think what people are going to
do with it.
So with WebRTC, the kind of
core of it is this idea of
voice and video calling.
That kind of makes sense.
So a lot of the optimizations
have been about working with
voice to essentially do what
you can do with telephony.
But we've also got this
ability to do really
high-quality video chat.
We're already seeing very good
quality, very low-latency
video chat, which
is fantastic.
The third part of the WebRTC
picture in a way is an API
called Data Channel.
Now, what that enables you to do
is arbitrary streaming data
between browsers.
So that's like anything.
So you could be streaming any
kind of arbitrary data, not
just audio video
data, anything.
So a stack of really--
I mean, who knows?
ALEKSEY: Oh yeah.
I can imagine quite a
few things already.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
ALEKSEY: So maybe
for developers,
what does RTC mean?
I mean, where do they get
started, and why is it even a
good thing in the first place?
I mean, they like Flash today,
and maybe that-- so just for
the player, that offers
some solution.
SAM DUTTON: Absolutely.
So, I mean, we've talked to
Flash developers who've kind
of had some struggles and are
really pleased to hear about
the project, in particular
because it's--
you know, WebRTC provides--
they're just APIs within the
browser, so they're really
easy to integrate with your
existing workflow and your
existing web apps.
ALEKSEY: It is web development,
right?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, it's
web development.
ALEKSEY: It's just another
API, right?
SAM DUTTON: It's not like you've
got to bring in the
Flash guy or the whatever, and
you've got people who work on
the web, who use the web, who
use the API, so that's the
first part.
The second big deal is that
there's no licensing.
Google has done a huge amount of
work on this stuff and made
it then open sourced and freely
available, so there's
no licensing for the developers
or for the end users.
So, it's good for everyone
ALEKSEY: OK, great.
So where should people go to
get started if they're
interested?
And what does the next six
months or 12 months or two
years look like?
SAM DUTTON: So the place
to start with WebRTC is
webrtc.org.
It's the kind of natural
home for WebRTC.
There's articles
on HTML5 Rocks.
There's a book called "WebRTC
Book," a really nice books for
the Kindle.
It's about six pounds
something.
It's cheap, about eight
euros, I think.
There's some great video, too.
Check out Justin Uberti's Google
I/O video, a really
good place to start.
And yeah, there's lots
of resources
online to get you started.
ALEKSEY: What does the roadmap
for WebRTC look like?
SAM DUTTON: So the next six
months, well, there's a lot of
work on keeping going with
standardization projects.
We want to integrate
Mozilla work.
WebRTC has just been implemented
in Firefox
nightlies in Aurora, and we
want to integrate the work
there with the work that's been
implemented in Chrome.
Obviously, there's a big
push now for mobile.
That's the kind of natural
home for personal
communication.
And then, of course, Data
Channel, to see an
implementation.
It is in Firefox, but we want
to see that in Chrome soon.
ALEKSEY: OK, wonderful.
So lots of things to look at.
SAM DUTTON: Yes, indeed.
ALEKSEY: Thanks, Sam.
SAM DUTTON: Cheers, Aleksey.
Good to talk.